but the why welcome to the why everyone
are you ready are you ready for the
rewind stinky stinky memes you know
that's what's gonna be this week let's
just jump into it roll the intro leave
your first one in 2018 we made something
you didn't like
so in 2019 dot dot dot I'll freakin do
it again that's right YouTube for those
who don't know YouTube also added a new
policy change for harassment so you're
not allowed to make fun of people's
appearance anymore but I'll freakin do
it anyway hey youtube you're ugly I
don't freaking care what are you gonna
do congratulations
oh yeah that's right it should have been
on the list but you know we said some
super hurtful things in there so it's
understandable
it definitely is a harassment Jesus
Christ oh god what has happened to
comedy we're boys cried we're men cried
a pearl g4 bad english
where were you when cut leg wind I'd I
was at house eating Dorito when phone
ring ring ring ring ring no penguin is
killed
I didn't think words could hear you no
sticks and stones don't break no bones
but this make them men tear a single
tear so sad so sad
iPod iPad hey boomer all right
iPod iPad I paid I oh nice nice very
nice meme when will your wife host
memory well first we have to get married
that this requirement well that's true
but the second requirement is yo he's
new PewDiePie thumbnails are sake that's
right I am on strike I refuse to make
another thumbnail with a different
stinky face and play into the whole
cringy this is my emotion the whole
video you YouTube Who am I even saying
it to you to Bri 1 2019 be like look at
this graph look at this inaccurate graph
look at this inaccurate data that we had
that's right I said dad I'm not data
okay gang let's see who's really behind
me when this year WatchMojo that's false
WatchMojo did an actual better version
so that's not really fair to WatchMojo
guys come on Showtime did you forget to
sell the tickets or something actually I
stole your friends to come it is a good
combat I really like it but you set
yourself up for that [ __ ] jacket you to
Bri one thanking me for watching the
video me whoever already disliked the
video Wow haha you guys hated the video
am i right hahahahahaha MRI gamers how
do you do fellow kids yeah I think it's
good that they did that but still it's
kind of rich bros the Golden Age squad
fam the Dark Age 9 year olds the
Renaissance 19 year olds the Great
Depression it doesn't get better that's
a man copper and edgy content being
slashed out in one month can't wait for
more mediocre humor on this platform
yeah
don't go too far that's harassment don't
go too far because we can't tell the
difference if you are genuine or joking
or not and we're not gonna bother
finding out so we're just gonna make
sure that all everything you say is
exactly serious but he said that I hate
I hate I [ __ ] hate I hate this
current climate
it's so stupid I think what bothers me
most about the current political climate
is the fact that you know the opinion
that the majority has isn't gonna be
remember in the future when they look
back at the shift happening now we're
all gonna look like idiots even if we're
criticizing it we're still gonna be
grouped in with all these morons who's
controlling what is happening do you
know what I mean
like even if we are fighting against it
or say like oh actually this is written
how can I say that oh no actually this
is stupid you're still gonna be
remembered as that group of morons dudes
hey you are 19 now 9 year olds 9 year
olds 19 year olds 19 year olds I've seen
this video it's great someone stop this
mad lad trying to find a doctor at an
anti vaccine rally it's really good
he goes out to people and say hey are
you auntie VAX they go yeah are you a
doctor no and it moves on no but my in
my opinion from looking at Google
research own Atrix did one for terraria
let's play that's awesome thank you very
much it's jacksepticeye I have Cthulhu
that's very very cool I can't wait to
see wall of flesh then Jesus Christ it's
been a great decade freaking I went from
SOI boy to hold boy man that's a man not
a boy okay I love killing rich people
cuz I get their loot it's epic that's
how it works
come on gamers everyone baby Odessa
cutest thing ever baby Edgar and Maya on
my gold that is so cute you to everyone
skipped over congratulations under most
like music video I know can you believe
it
I can why there's no one like this one
when your cousin deletes your Mario Kart
save file so you delete him from the
family tree a shoulder for a so Mario
Kart save file what
what are you my it's the Mario 64's a
file
oh my god that happened to me I was so
angry it's [ __ ] friend that I have I
won't say his name but you know who you
are it's been a great decade haha and
not expect that well play la la oh la la
hey yo yo ye hey I don't know which
elevators permits it from Full Metal
Alchemist are you going most underrated
tweet of the decade Gundam is better
than sex
marzia have fun building never joke
about pee-pee small Pepe whoa what the
hell I look up Captain bro fish at your
service Pete if I should say how's it
going bros my name is PewDiePie one last
time this decade how's it going bro man
that's as good as I can get everyone
after seeing you - rewind come on do
something
come on do something oh I got the power
back I don't know how I can do that oh
the light the swell pretty vice the most
hated youtuber according to Google this
is my theory like people are just riding
dumb titles as a way to get people to
click on it that's the only reason
they're in business oh because they
googled most hated youtubers and there's
an article from like years ago isn't it
yeah it is this is so old plus it shows
yep all PewDiePie's the most hated
youtuber according to Google Scrolls
down number one Jake Paul alright good
job you had one job the grind is real
you flirt and kiss and for what sex love
pathetic to level my Christmas debt I
can respect that
ah a gamer at last you may pass wrapper
dice people who didn't even know that he
existed f he was like father to me
are you referring juice world don't ever
make that into a joke my dad is the best
at making surprises and your your phone
dad my mom would put the doughnut in the
iPhone box I would do that too
kids don't deserve phones I'm just gonna
say it is this from frozen oh my god it
totally
looks like me what the heck is so
awkward that is so awkward best youtuber
of the beginning of the decade best
youtuber at the end of the decade
that's right ten years gamers I've been
actually doing it for ten years that's
crazy
UK house floods Japan house gets robbed
minecraft house catches on fire
terraria house I'm in danger oh my god I
don't even want to think good eye my
terraria how can they burn down can
something happen to the houses a letter
for you
team trees just need two million two
hundred eighty four thousand more trees
and we can do it come on
gamers come on let's smash it my comic
was right I saw this on Twitter it's so
good was Rosa five feet of my memory so
I turn him into a smug anime girl listen
I would put pipi and PewDiePie Chan I'm
just gonna say it I mean that no make it
like this yeah this is how they drew
cars as kids idiots
everyone is such a boring this is how
you draw cars as a champ if you didn't
draw cars like this there must have been
something wrong with you
I think it's cuz we have the candy that
looks like that in Sweden the belie
right oh my god straw boy bill Eric's
face look right there has to be it oh my
god and the fatality below oh my god
amazing amazing drawing Merryweather II
check her out super cool best scene and
the whole rewind 2019 changed my mind
and the peopie chair made it in rewind
two years in a row baby let's get three
come on chair let's get a round of
applause for peopie chair italian here
yeah my just sent me this she thought it
was so funny italian air youtube freaks
up rewind pewdiepie okay my turn
alright if this video gets 200,000 likes
will do another rewind that's because
we're definitely not doing it anyway
i am an animated Sven and his ac-130
lockheed Bombur
yeah I know it was just supposed to be a
b-52 but I it wrong for some reason I
had a brain bad that's so cool
peachy fried well done I love cement as
well it's the shame those videos don't
think well but I still really enjoy
making them Felix when it's yuki house
gets flooded Felix when his Japanese
house gets flooded Felix when his mind
round half-bred you've gone too far
Society you've gone too far and I'm not
happy about it
you take away someone's minecraft house
my brother's brothers reaction to being
on the line okay so that was him oh well
I made at one gamer smile at 1/9 you're
all Americans Australians oh wow that's
so cool I never thought of that
you have small peepee you have small
peepee you have big peepee you're
watching this very big peepee we're
wholesome on this channel I don't know
what the same I'm gonna pretend I didn't
see that
can you Matt in the board meetings we
can't put congratulations in there we
can celebrate t-series as much as we
want but oh god what what would happen
why there's no one like why didn't no
one like to rewind this year
minecraft part 1 2 million likes rerun
doesn't include correlations in the top
most like news videos oops oops didn't
think we'd see everyone wow such a good
representation of men slow descent into
madness
me and him telling ya that was a real
time that was dark times we don't talk
about that on this channel anymore the
sacred text that's not too hard to learn
some of them makes sense like you that's
the face I make when I say u u L that's
the face I say when I make L duck in
game stop I was buying minecraft story
mode stop stalking me please
yeah it's really rude to take photos of
celebrities in public so don't do that
to Dolan he doesn't deserve it was this
the foreshadowing to that duck game the
chemo
what crime did this tree commit to be
put in tree jail no treason this is the
guy who still can't build a cobblestone
generator hey they're hard to make I
don't understand the science these type
of structures they're not hard to build
they just look complicated but and they
all are run the same push mechanic
premise like it's not it's everybody's
fun though I like it read it upload
button changing precision home comfort
deserves team trees and European rating
the Vatican I forgot about that are we
gonna read it or what come on gamers I
need something good in my life
petition for Felix to bring back his
cardboard family no I refuse maybe when
I'm in Japan and I need friends no it
doesn't affect my baby baby oh that
should be meme of the decade funny
because he's cute and that's all he does
me after having a fun and respectful
online match GG surprisingly wholesome
how about that my meme gets into the why
Felix the council will decide what is
this god-awful image what is that the
council has chosen large PP well done
very well reacting to me running out our
content I'm running out of content
hey this guy's stealing my formula
improvise adapt overcome my brain when
I'm trying to go to sleep my brain
directs ok alright ok
my friends wasting your time riding mine
all day in the intergalactic alphabet
won't get you on the why am i all day oh
wow they did it amazing big that's big
PP energy right there felt cute might
delete Wow you keep digging up old
photos don't you you think you're soaked
where did you find this where did you
find this where did you find this
there's a chance that someone thought
about merging you but decided not to
well of course I know he's good name
large PP energy on this one its rewind
time everybody
this wasn't rewind this is repose
no no he's got a point the way it works
is very simple that bad kid
not bad it is simple that's the best
designs are the ones that that is like
that banana duct tape to wall by
Maurizio's at the Lancer I feel like
this whole thing is just set up some guy
took it down and ate it as well and it
just screams marketing ploy bullish I am
not buying it small peepee energy
downvoted your meme doesn't get into the
why your meme gets into the why your
meme gets into the why and pute says you
have big peepee your meme is using the
thumbnail small peepee so I for no
reason just for no reason when YouTube
uses your own clip in the rewind and you
copy strike time big brain oh yeah it's
payback brain time it's brain back time
I like that I like that nobody YouTube
you're like stats you know and I see
some stats my phone apparently
everyone's phone on ready oh you mean
like this whatever is the to rent phone
it's whatever I'm joking
this is my favorite drawing ever I drew
it on black paper it was difficult but
it paid off
I was only drawing for six hours hope
Peter pie likes it very cool big energy
big pee pee pee deep I should make you
something you to read one where he
starts off by digging it out to play
money buried into 2013 that was the last
good rewind as well there you have it
gamers it's time to dug back up what
this dead yeah I'll really play Lego
Star Wars yeah play drew Marzia
attention peopie during christmas
monsters inter-are I can draw presents
and you can get a dog dog whistle I like
it from it which you will makes men
follow you everywhere and he can't oh my
god
it's Christmas time it's Christmas time
we need to spend in Terraria
should I Pierce Grande flying killing
don't like make it rewind 2019 like last
year well-well-well gamers look like
it's time for the me and the boys to get
back again people complaining about the
uploaded vote and people that literally
don't care left-handed people people who
didn't even notice it
yeah it's weird I don't understand their
reddit complaining about your head have
you seen YouTube have you seen the
changes they make their reddit they
change one tiny thing all my
me singing enemy opening my Japanese
friend amazing everything words he said
is wrong yeah people make a Swedish
accent amazing every single word you
said was correct that's how we talk
pflueger's Mugen friggin fluid and OH
flesh Megan [ __ ] Hagen I see you speak
Swedish when you see the sub trying to
push kids to play like a Star Wars
laughing sift Lord I already played it
my granddad got your nose five-year-old
me I'm not afraid to kill him I'm not
afraid if it's necessary I will do a big
peepee energy I like that i like
terraria memes top 3 pewdiepie that
appears kpop huge 30 year old man Lich I
live in France basement play with
breasts struggle if you I should grow
out my beard or not I keep pushing out
cuz it looks so bad in that period can't
stand it doesn't look every good I
should just shave every hair off 19 year
old Christmas March ugly pity PI I love
it oh yeah make sure you order before
now you should order it now so it
arrives in time for Christmas we got sue
caveat we got the jacket super cool a
safe sook up yet if your epic fully
stack diamond if your minecraft 100 mil
if you're a gamer thanks for supporting
the channel appreciate it look forward
to see you guys wearing it this meat
like I genuinely I don't care but it's
weird seeing YouTube celebrate it right
it feels like rubbing it in your face
it's amazing to think what great and
exciting things people will be doing
with pieces in 30 years
big BP the chips at the top of the bag
the chips at the bottom of the bag good
name Beauty pie pick sling greatest game
of all time after poopy of course or
equal sorry haha that's really correct
possibly incorrect resume correction
expression new password kept be the same
as old password big BP can't relate
pewdiepie shared attempt to 404
challenge set up a gaming beta created
in your world with the seed for a for
collect resources until night fold break
the big patch of gravel enter the
massive cabe you just entered never
if you die restart I'm not gonna die I
don't die in games I'm not a coward
maybe I'll try that that could be fun
you think this is funny oh I copyright
claim my own YouTube video to get it
ramana Thais YouTube 2019 everyone rain
tea and tea but spend Avella - just aa
big ppppp minecraft game of the decade
you heard it here first gamers alright
well that's it for this week slow I
again if you want to check out the merge
now is the time to do it also check out
pooped eats out I'm sorry I'm always
like shove it down your throat I promise
there won't be as much in the future
just kind of things happen at the same
time it is a legitimately good game and
I think you guys will like it and yeah
that's it for now see you guys bye bye
now you are entering a new era where you
shall craft the home
[Music]
fart smells and poop breezes coming
marnya Edgar and buckells need you
the diaper you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne booty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prizes
you